angenehm angenehm
hallo mein name ist meyer hallo mein
name ist meyer angenehm müller angenehm
müller freut mich freut mich
guten tag mein name ist müller
guten tag mein name ist müller freut
mich herr müller freut mich herr müller
grüßen grüßen
schönen tag
wer war die frau die du eben gegrüßt
hast
hast winken
winken
wer ist der junge der dir zuwinkt
sich verabschieden
es war mir ein vergnügen sie
kennenzulernen es war mir ein vergnügen
sie kennenzulernen
ich verabschiede mich jetzt ich
verabschiede mich jetzt
kennen
kennst du den neuen bio laden an der
ecke
kennenlernen
wie habt ihr euch kennengelernt wie habt
ihr euch kennengelernt
hallo schön dich kennenzulernen
hallo schön dich kennenzulernen treffen
treffen
wir treffen uns um 19 uhr vor dem kino
hockey
okay
vorstellen
ich möchte ihnen eine neue mitarbeiterin
der besuch der besuch
ich freue mich über deinen besuch
[Musik]
besuch haben besuch haben
ich kann nicht ich kann nicht ich habe
heute abend besucht zum abendessen
ich habe heute abend besucht zum
abendessen
[Musik]
besuchen besuchen
kaum uns bald wieder besuchen
kam uns bald wieder besuchen einladen
einladen
darf ich dich zum essen einladen
darf ich dich zum essen einladen mit
kommen
mit kommen
wir gehen essen kommt ihr auch mit
geben
können sie mir bitte die quittung geben
wärst du so gut und gibt die dokumente
bei herrn müller ab
wärst du so gut und gibt es die
dokumente bei herrn müller ab
okay geben sie mir bitte bescheid
nehmen
nee
[Musik]
bist du bereit
bist du bereit ja ich nehme die jacke
und kommet
ja ich nehme die jacke und kann moment
was wollen wir zum nachtisch nehmen
bringen
kannst du bitte das besteck bringen
die frage die frage
ich weiß nicht wie ich dich frage
beantworten soll
fragen fragen
darf ich sie etwas fragen darf ich sie
etwas fragen
ich denke dass sich nach dem weg fragen
muss
nachfragen
ich habe es nicht verstanden und musste
noch einmal nachfragen
bitten
bitte ruhe
kannst du mir bitte helfen
kannst du mir bitte helfen schenken
schenken
er hat mir zum geburtstag blumen
geschenkt
das geschenk
das ist ein schönes geschenk
der dank
vielen dank für deinen geschenkt
danken
danke für deine hilfe
nichts zu danken nichts zu danken
[Musik]
sich bedanken
ich möchte mich noch einmal sehr
herzlich für ihre hilfe bedanken
keine ursache keine ursache
keine
sache keine ursache
sich streiten sich
m
sie streiten sich seit 30 minuten
der streit
ich möchte deswegen keinen streit
streiten streiten
ich will nicht mehr darüber streiten ich
will nicht mehr darüber streiten
leid tun
es tut mir leid ich wollte nicht
streiten
es tut mir leid dass du dich mit deiner
freundin gestritten hast
die entschuldigung die entschuldigung
entschuldigung darf ich dich kurz stern
entschuldigung da richtig kurz stern
verzeihen verzeihen
verzeihen sie wo geht es hier zum
bahnhof
die fed
die verzeihung
verzeihung ich habe die falsche nummer
gewählt
wie viele wörter kanntest du schon
hast du eine frage schreibt sie in die
kommentare und hinterlasst uns ein like
[Musik]
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video